[Music]
what if someday we decided that the
usefulness of our planet had run its
course and humans needed to scour space
to find somewhere new to live but
instead of finding a potentially
habitable earth-like exoplanets
light-years away we build our own
artificial world right here in the solar
system what kind of technology would we
need to manufacture a new planet where
would we find enough raw materials for
our future world and how long would it
take us to finish this planetary
construction project this is what if and
here's what would happen if we built an
artificial planet rocky planets like
Earth are born from the leftover
material of a newly formed star they
start off as grains of dust smaller than
the width of a human hair
these grains fuse into larger chunks
that keep colliding with each other
until after a few million years they
develop into a new terrestrial world
theoretically we understand how planets
are formed in the universe but how would
we go about manufacturing an artificial
one if we humans were to build a
planetary replica and populate it we'd
have to churn out a rock with an
atmosphere of breathable air the right
temperature earth-like gravity and a
stable orbit around the Sun and that's
just for starters
we'd start the construction in the sun's
habitable zone that would help us
maintain earth-like temperatures on our
artificial planet but where would we
find all the materials to build it
asteroids might seem like a good source
the problem is the earth has the mass of
over 2000 asteroid belts there's simply
not enough asteroids in the solar system
to build a new earth sized world but
there could be enough materials in the
Oort cloud the swarm of icy debris that
hypothetically exists in the outermost
reaches of the solar system but this
cloud is so far away that even Voyager 1
that's been traveling at 17 km/s for the
past 41 years won't reach it for another
300 years and it won't make it to the
other side of the Oort cloud for about
30
thousand years we'd need to build some
faster spacecraft to get all that dust
and nudge it in the right direction we
could also start stealing moons from
other planets all of Jupiter's moons for
example would give us enough material to
craft a planet about 7% the size of
Earth that would be a good start if we
could manage to pull them out of
Jupiter's orbit it wouldn't be necessary
to build our new world as big as the
earth to replicate the same force of
gravity we feel now if we could pack
1/10 of the Earth's mass into a sphere
the size of the moon it would do the
same trick still it would take us at
least several hundred years to finish
the construction once all the
engineering issues were solved and our
newly formed artificial planet settled
into orbit around the Sun we dumped in
some water we'd let it evaporate to
create the atmosphere we could even
inject some of the carbon dioxide
released by polluting industries on
earth then we bring in the plants plants
would slowly build up oxygen in the
atmosphere through photosynthesis
finally after millennia of planet
building the first human colonies would
set foot on the new terrestrial
human-made planet even though it would
be smaller in size the Earth's replica
wouldn't see much different from the
original earth-like temperatures and
gravity would make it feel like our home
planet but it wouldn't be as stable as
the earth our artificial world would
require active maintenance from the
planetary environment to our orbital
parameters currently there's so much we
don't know about the universe and we can
only guess how a new planet would form
within it at this point it may be easier
to terraform an existing world instead
of building a totally new one but that's
a story for another what if
you